happy and Tuesday oh yes I love you I
love every single one of you
I love every single one of you even the
unattractive ones
I love you even more you've been through
a lot being so ugly all right it's time
to get excited because we're doing this
[Music]
all right now typically I only give this
the audience two topics but tonight I'm
feeling generous and I propose a
three-way
why waste the Viagra am I right
so I'll present each choice and then
you'll applaud and the one that gets the
most hooting and hollering wins you know
it's like a wet t-shirt contest at your
local Cracker Barrel
why did they stop that topic one
Sweden could follow in America's
footsteps and spiral into a recession
because their GDP has shrunken more than
expected as you know Sweden is famous
for producing Ann-Margret and wood
who likes that one
all right not into Sweden it's too bad
we had that ABBA medley ready to go
all right topic to a story we've barely
covered the Canadian trans teacher with
fake breasts so huge the cup sizes
Himalayas
[Music]
[Applause]
all right not bad not bad
okay that's good that's good now on to
topic three Elon Musk will be here on
set to share a discovery of a substance
that will cure aging cancer in virtually
all other diseases it could triple our
lifespans and it's free to everyone
crap
now
all right that's amazing all right
looks like Elon and the Aging cure is
the winner here oh sorry my producer uh
just being told in my ear that the bad
weather has canceled elon's flight
yeah you can't make it he can't make it
well son of a looks like Captain
wins
[Applause]
that was a close one
so what's the latest on the high school
Woodshop teacher whose favorite project
is always a giant rack hit it
if it happens up there we report down
here you're watching gazumba gate
Canada 2023
4.
Ontario's Halton District School Board
has finally adopted a new policy
regarding Kayla
Lemieux and her cartoonish knockers now
for those of you just hearing about this
story I'm sorry for your loss
so here's a recap
she was once a he began identifying as
female last year and started wearing
massive prosthetic breasts to class the
school board still stands behind the
teacher no other choice
the post obtained photos of Lemieux
outside of school without the breasts
dressed as a man he tells the post he's
not transgendered at all but was born
intersex and they're due to a rare
medical condition called
gigantomasia it's a word I had to Google
and then keep doing an image search for
several hours
well after months of Parental outrage
Global attention and cravings for dairy
the school board has released a
so-called professionalism policy for
parent review but it contains no details
on dresss for teachers and you thought
our school boards were filled with
idiots get a load of what these Geniuses
came up with quote the purpose of this
policy is to consolidate and affirm
existing expectations regarding staff
professionalism including dress and
decorum at board and school settings and
at school-based activities focusing on
the importance of demonstrating through
personal presentation respect for public
education and each student's right to
learn in a safe inclusive and accepting
environment
Jesus that's basically the only spot in
the entire document that mentions dress
and I should know I made a minimum wage
intern read the policy several times
while waxing my back
yet no it's a mistake yet nowhere in
that mismatch of respect inclusivity
safety and more Canadian level
politeness does it say and don't strap
on a pair of knobs that could breastfeed
King Kong and Godzilla
the policy is supposed to be presented
to the board on Wednesday but without a
dress code for employees like Kayla what
good will it do other than provide this
show and this audience with another
Year's worth of great content I'm
starting to think these School
administrators watch this show and love
basking in the Limelight certainly the
same school that has a dress code for
Halloween would have a dress code for
every other damn day
but it all boils down to what I've been
saying for a while Kayla could be the
greatest troll in the history of trolls
so as the teacher proved her point
or rather points
Kayla could be exposing among other
things the lunacy of the woke agenda a
world where no one dare criticized or
much less passive dress code policy
without fear of being labeled to
transphobe he's calling their Bluff with
breast the size of Boulders and
everybody pretends he's legit even when
the proof is staring you in the face
like a pair of plastic areolas
or as I call them scaryolas
remember we called it before this is a
costume and it's worn only at certain
times it's fetishistic and I'm still
shocked that there's no social media
footprint of this teacher before his
transition I mean what are the odds of
that a person at the center of a crazy
stunt never been on Twitter Facebook
Instagram Tick Tock and what about his
family or his friends it's so quiet you
could hear a boob drop
of course Kayla really could be flat out
Bonkers as she told the New York Post
recently she's not wearing fake breasts
they're real
although Brian stelter told the post the
same thing when they saw him at a
holiday in pool in Yonkers
okay
wear a t-shirt Brian but but no they
aren't real you have a bigger chance
than a pair of Chinese spy balloons
floated off course and into her sweater
so ultimately I made it go to my grave
never knowing the real story behind
those Titanic
but I'd rather die seeking the truth and
live in the shadows of those giant
magnificent bazoons
[Applause]
he doesn't wear LL Bean because he says
it looks too Urban Fox News contributor
Tom salou
she puts her money where her mouth is
which is dangerous because you could
choke and die Fox Business anchor Lauren
Simonetti
he is to woke culture what the health
department is to the Views bathroom
author of the book the new Puritans
Andrew Doyle
[Applause]
[Music]
and she's wise Beyond her years it's
something no one has ever said Fox News
contributor Kat Tiff
Andrew I have to go to you first because
you are a notorious prankster I mean you
played the role of Tatiana to otatina
Titanium whatever you want to say yeah
you got you Brits always screw up words
so we mess up your language exactly
exactly
that is true and you don't let us forget
it
um but um you pretended to be somebody
else and to great effect and you have a
theory here what do you think is going
on well I used to agree with you and I
used to think that this was a troll that
this was someone trying to expose the
absurdity of gender identity ideology
I've now come to the conclusion it's
real it's two there's too much
commitment right you know and then there
was that interview mentioned where this
guy says these are real they're not
prosthetic at all and I did Google that
and there is a condition that would
explain that it's what's it called lying
yeah that's uh that's what it's known as
yeah
um but it's fascinating what's been
really interesting to me is the reaction
from the school board because they've
been so determined to sort of defend the
teacher saying well this is a minority
group this is an oppressed minority this
is someone who's vulnerable and that
really the media we shouldn't be talking
about we should leave him alone right
right but I mean like and look at look
at this person I mean clearly there is a
point there because clearly this is the
sort of person that hates being the
center of attention exactly they hate it
so leave me alone you know what they are
they're the Canadian version of Meghan
Markle and Prince Harry that's right
yeah who are also two
laughs
thank you at least one person applauded
I think in England that means something
that I ate differently right no that's
twits I don't know Tom I I mean I can't
tell I don't know do you have a um
Theory you know you think you're a deep
thinker I I think I don't know if well
you could say is it a troll or isn't it
a troll but is a troll only when you are
trying to Lampoon the absurdity of it or
could you be trolling just for another
reason I don't know what the definition
of it is really but they said they were
going to revise the dress code they were
like we're going to look at the dress
code but the thing is her dress code
isn't offensive she looks like a Mormon
PE teacher you know what I mean like
with the clothes with the clothes yeah
like clothes are fine the clothes are
absolutely conservative right so if you
know I think that she thought of he I
don't even say she the guy thought of it
before he did the whole thing he's not
wearing provocative clothing so you
can't call them on that so I read this
whole thing did you see the document it
doesn't say anything it goes on for page
after page and it does but I don't know
if it matters I don't know if it matters
if it's a troll or not because you have
guys like Andrew I enjoy his character
you know when you see this lampooning
character he does but I also enjoy just
as much the regular social justice
Warriors it's based on right and I
laughed just as much of that I think
which one is more entertaining to me
they're both equally entertaining and
they're both equally as instructive in
their absurdity and I think whether this
is a troll or whether it isn't uh he's
still annoying people I mean they they
should still remove him from the school
and the fact that the school is
paralyzed shows so much it's amazing I
mean he's he's telling an amazing story
this is a I know it was a South Park uh
plot uh years ago I believe and but this
is like an incredible uh it's an
achievement it's performance art yes so
whether he's whether he's doing it as
performance art or he's doing it
seriously it's making the same point it
matters because they've been bomb
threats to the school now so some people
are so obsessed about it I mean are they
bum threats or they're just worried that
one of the breasts will pop I don't know
but this goal in its report has now said
there's no urgency to resolve this
matter I think bomb threats for a school
should be resolved sooner rather than
later doesn't he that's a good yeah it's
a great point because then you're
venturing into something dangerous
Lauren I'm a little disappointed in in
Fox Business for not covering the story
no I I I I did I went down a deep dark
hole like just Googling and then I
wanted to hear her voice that was trying
to find videos you know what is this
really like yeah and I spent way too
much time and then I yeah it was
voyeuristic I said I just I had to stop
but the parents of the school district
have two GoFundMe Pages they're
legitimately trying to raise ten
thousand dollars fifteen thousand
dollars to Sue this District because
this is so unfortunate for the kids and
it's a safety hazard yeah she can't
stand like that in front of wood cutters
and saws yes I mean something needs to
be done just for the safety of of her
yeah exactly and the students and I
always teach my kids dress for the job
you want yes that is not how you're
supposed to dress imagine be fired
imagine the job that he wants oh I don't
know cat yeah you told me this morning
that you were so happy we're covering
this story and that there's been some
progress made uh you've been doing some
of your own like uh dogged research and
Reporting what can you tell us what can
you share with us today yeah Lauren you
said you went down the rabbit hole I've
been forced down this Rabbit Hole
every single well I spend months now
probably yeah yeah but I would also be
remiss if I did not bring up the fact
that I am also wearing a costume yes
every single night on this show yeah
some of the audience knows whenever I
will walk straight through the audience
to come into the studio for hair and
makeup I never get high cat I'll get is
that cat
because I don't look like this
um look I mean what is there to say I
mean there's always something to say
school is in a bind which they did that
thing where if you like ask your boss
for a raise and the next day you get an
email like great news casual Fridays are
back they're trying to kind of distract
because they don't feel like they can do
anything and when this came out I was on
a plane when it first came out that you
know this old pictures from the New York
Post dressed as a man I was like this
doesn't mean it's over because you can
say non-binary that's their gender
gender fluid where you're like more of a
girl some days and more of a guy other
days and and I just I'm also just I
haven't had any additional information
despite my desperate pleas to the entire
country of Canada uh and if I could give
back all the money I spent buying Jager
Bombs there on my 19th birthday that I
contributed to my their economy in the
great city of Windsor I would
well we will remain
on top of this story
like the world's largest sports bra
up next do you ever notice how people
are now wearing sports bra without
anything else
like no shirt or no yeah no sir just
people walking around at sports bras
Boomer thing you've ever said it's it's
uh it's just in my neighborhood anyway
we're gonna get to the bottom of that
Tuesday during the break hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else